turn to our jails that would be a good
thing
[Applause]
the Senate will convene as a court of
impeachment the chaplain will lead us in
prayer let us pray
eternal Lord God you have summarized
ethical behavior in a single sentence do
for others what you would like them to
do for you remind our senators that they
alone are accountable to you for their
conduct Lord help them to remember that
they can't ignore you and get away with
it for we always reap what we sow have
your way mighty God you are the Potter
our senators and we are the clay mold
and make us after your will stand up
omnipotent God stretch yourself and let
this nation and world know that you
alone are sovereign I pray in the name
of Jesus please join me in reciting the
pledge of allegiance to the flag
yep done
senators please be seated if there is no
objection the journal of proceedings of
the trial are approved to date the
deputy sergeant at arms will make the
proclamation hear ye hear ye hear ye all
persons are commanded to keep silent on
pain of imprisonment while the Senate of
the United States is sitting for the
trials trial of articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States the
majority leader is recognized for the
information of all colleagues we'll take
a break about two hours out pursuant to
the provisions of Senate resolution 483
the Senate has provided up to four hours
of argument by the parties equally
divided on the question of whether or
not it shall be in order to consider and
debate under the impeachment rules any
motion to subpoena witnesses or
documents mr. manager Schiff are you a
proponent or opponent mr. Cipollone II
are you a proponent or opponent thank
you then mr. Schiff you may proceed
before I begin mr. Chief Justice the
house managers will be reserving the
balance of our time to respond to the
argument of counsel for the president
mr. chief justice
senators fellow house managers and
counsel for the president I know I speak
for my fellow managers as well as
counsel for the president in thanking
you for your careful attention to the
arguments that we have made over the
course of many long days today we were
greeted to yet another development in
the case when the New York Times
reported with a headline that says Trump
told Bolton to help his Ukraine pressure
campaign book says the president asked
his national security advisor last
spring in front of other senior advisors
to pave the way for a meeting between
Rudolph Giuliani and Ukraine's new
leader according to New York Times more
than two months before he asked
Ukraine's President to investigate his
political opponents President Trump
directed John R Bolton then his national
security adviser to help with his
pressure campaign to extract damaging
information on Democrats from Ukrainian
officials according to an unpublished
manuscript by mr. Bolton mr. Trump gave
the instruction mr. Bolton wrote during
an Oval Office conversation in early May
that included the acting White House
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and the White House Counsel Pat
Cipollone II who is now leading the
president's impeachment defense now you
will see in a few moments and you will
recall mr. SIPP Aloni
suggesting that the house managers were
concealing facts from this body he said
all the facts should come out well
there's a new fact which indicates that
mr. soup alone II was among those who
are in the loop yet another reason why
we ought to hear from witnesses just as
we predicted and it didn't require any
great act of clairvoyance the facts will
come
out they will continue to come out and
the question before you today is whether
they will come out in time for you to
make a complete and informed judgment as
to the guilt or innocence of the
president now that Times article goes on
to say that mr. Trump told mr. Bolten to
call Vladimir szalinski who had recently
won election as president of Ukraine to
ensure mr. szalinski would meet with mr.
Giuliani who was planning a trip to
Ukraine to discuss the investigations
that the president sought in mr.
Bolton's account mr. Bolten never made
the call he wrote never made the call
mr. Bolten understood that this was
wrong he understood that this was not
policy understood that this was a
domestic political errand and refused to
make the call the account mr. Bolton's
manuscript portrays the most senior
White House advisors as early witnesses
in the effort that they have sought to
distance the president from including
the White House Counsel over several
pages according to The Times mr. Bolton
laid out mr. Trump's fixation on Ukraine
and the president's belief based on a
mix of scattershot events assertions and
outright conspiracy theories that
Ukraine tried to undermine his chances
of winning the presidency in 2016 as he
began to realize the extent and aims of
the pressure campaign mr. Bolton began
to object he wrote in the book affirming
the testimony of a former National
Security Council aide fiona hill who had
said that mr. Bolton warned that mr.
Giuliani was a hand-grenade
who's going to blow everybody up now as
you might imagine the president denies
this president said today I never
instructed John Bolton to set up a
meeting for Rudy Giuliani one of
America's one of the greatest corruption
fighters in America
so here you have the president saying
John Bouldin is not telling the truth
let's find out
let's put john bolton under oath let's
find out who's telling the truth the
trial is supposed to be a quest for the
truth let's not fear what we will learn
as mr. Sibal oni said let's make sure
that all the facts come out
mr. chief justice
senators counsel for the president last
Tuesday at the onset of this trial we
mood for a leader McConnell's resolution
to be amended to subpoena documents and
witnesses from the onset from the outset
this body decided to hold the question
over you have now heard opening
arguments from both sides you have seen
the evidence that the house was able to
collect you have heard about the
documents and witnesses president Trump
blocked from the houses impeachment
inquiry we have vigorously questioned
both sides the president's counsel has
urged you to decide this case and render
your verdict upon the record assemble by
the house the evidence in the record is
sufficient it is sufficient to convict
the President on both articles of
impeachment more than sufficient but
that's simply not how trials work as any
prosecutor or defense lawyer would tell
you when a case goes to trial both sides
call witnesses and subpoena documents to
bring before the jury that happens every
day in courtrooms all across America
there is no reason why this impeachment
trial should be any different the common
sense practice is born out of precedents
there has never been never before been a
full Senate and Pietschmann trial
without a single witness in fact you can
see in the slide and every one of the 15
prior impeachment trials the Senate has
called multiple witnesses today we ask
you to follow this body's uniform
precedents and your common sense
we urge you
to vote in favor of subpoenaing
witnesses and documents now I'd like to
address one question at the offset there
has been much back and forth about
whether if the house believe it in its
it has sufficient evidence to convict
which we do why do we need more
witnesses and documents so I'd like to
be clear the evidence presented over the
past week and a half strongly supports a
vote to convict the president the
evidence is overwhelming we have a
mounting of evidence it's direct is
corroborated by multiple sources and it
proves that the president committed
grave impeachable offenses to cheat in
the next election the evidence confirms
that if left in office President Trump
will continue to harm our America's
national security he will continue to
seek to corrupt the upcoming election
and he will undermine he will undermine
our democracy all to further his own
personal gain but this is a fundamental
question that must be addressed is this
a fair trial is this a fair trial
is this a fair trial without the ability
to call witnesses and produce documents
the answer is clearly and unequivocally
no it was the president's decision to
contest the facts and that is his right
but because he has chosen to confess the
fact a contest the facts he shall not be
heard to complain he shall not be heard
to complain that the house wishes to
further prove his guilt
to answer the questions he would raise
he complains that few witnesses spoke
directly to the president about his
misconduct beyond his damn in
conversations with Sandlin and Mulvaney
okay let's hear from others then the
witnesses the house wishes the call
directly to the president's own words
his own admissions of guilt his own
confessions of responsibility if they
did not all the president's men would be
on their witness list not ours
these witnesses and the documents that
their agencies produce tell the full
story and I believe that we are
interested in hearing the full story you
should want to hear it more than that
the American people we know they want to
hear it the House Republicans on expert
witness in the house
professor Turley said if you could prove
the president used our military aid to
pressure Ukraine to investigate a
political rival and interfere in our
elections it would be an impeachable
abuse of power and Senator Graham to
recognize that if such evidence existed
it could potentially change his mind on
impeachment well we now have another
witness a fact witness who would
reportedly say exactly that ambassador
Bolton's new manuscript which we will
discuss in more detail in a moment
reportedly confirms that the president
told him and no uncertain terms we're
talking about the former national
security adviser saying the president
told him in no uncertain terms no aid
until investigations including the
Biden's for a week and a half the
president has said no
such evidence exists they are wrong but
if you have any doubt about the evidence
if you have any doubt about the evidence
the evidence is at your fingertips the
question is will you let all of us
including the American people here
simply hear the evidence and make up
their own minds and you can make up your
own minds but will we let the American
people hear all of the evidence you
recall that ambassador bolt and the
president's former national security
adviser is one of the witnesses we asked
for last Tuesday we did not know at the
time what he'd say we didn't know what
kind of witness that he would be but
ambassador Bolton made clear that he was
willing to testify and that he had
relevant first-hand knowledge that it
hadn't yet been heard we urge we argued
that we all deserve to hear that
evidence but the president opposed him
now we know why because John Bolton
could corroborate the rest of our
evidence and confirm the president's
guilt so today today senators we come
before you and we urge we argue again
that you let this witness and the other
key witnesses we have identified come
forward so you have all of the
information available to you when you
make this consequential decision if
witnesses are not called here these
proceedings will be a trial in name only
and the American people clearly know a
fair trial when they see one large
majorities of the American people want
to hear from witnesses in this trial
and they have a right to hear from
witnesses in this trial let's hear from
them
let's look them in the eye gauge their
credibility and hear what they have to
say about the president's actions for
the same reasons this body should grant
our request to subpoena documents the
documents that the president also bought
the house from obtaining documents from
the White House the State Department DoD
and OMB that will complete the story and
provide the whole truth whatever they
may be we ask that you subpoena these
documents so that you can decide for
yourself if you have any doubt as to
what occurred let's look at this
additional evidence to be clear we're
not asking you to track down every
single document or to call every
possible witness we have carefully
identified only four key witnesses with
direct knowledge who can speak to the
specific issues that the president has
disputed and we targeted key documents
which we understand have already been
collected for example at the State
Department
they've already been collected they this
will not cause a substantial delay as I
made clear last night these matters can
be addressed in a single week as we made
clear last night these matters can be
addressed in a single week we know that
from President Clinton's case there the
Senate voted to approve a motion for
witnesses On January 27 the next day it
established procedures for those
depositions and adjourned as a court of
impeachment until February 4 in that
brief period the parties took three
depositions the Senate didn't then
resumed its proceedings by voting to
accept the deposition testimony into the
record
in this trial - let's do the same we
should take a brief one-week break for
witness testimony and document
collection during which time the Senate
can return to its normal business the
trial should not be allowed to be
different from each from every other
impeachment trial or any other kind of
trial simply because the president
doesn't want us to know the truth the
American people the American people that
we all represent the American people
that we all love and care about deserve
to know the truth and a fair trial
requires it this is too important of a
decision to be made without all of the
relevant evidence before turning to the
specific need for these witnesses and
documents I want to make clear we are
not asking you again to break new ground
we're asking quite the opposite we're
asking you to simply follow the Senate's
unbroken precedents and to do so in a
manner that allows you to continue the
sentence ordinary business the Senate
sitting as a court of impeachment has
heard witness testimony and every other
as we've said earlier in every other 15
impeachment trials in the history of the
Republic and in fact these trials have
had an average of 33 witnesses and the
Senate has repeatedly subpoenaed and
received new documents while
adjudicating cases of impeachment that
makes sense
under our Constitution the Senate does
not just vote on impeachments it does
not just debate them instead the Senate
is commanded by the Constitution to try
all cases of impeachment well the trial
requires
witnesses a trial requires documents
this is the American Way and this is the
American story if the Senate denies our
emotions it would be the only time in
history it has written it a judgment on
articles of impeachment without hearing
from a single witness or receiving a
single relevant document from the
president whose conduct is on trial and
why why can we justify how can we
justify this break from precedents how
would we justify for what reason would
we break precedents in these proceedings
there are many compelling reasons beyond
precedents that demand subpoenas for
witnesses and cases and documents in
this case and at this time I yield to
manager Garcia
mr. chief justice
president's counsel senators last week I
shared with you that I was reflecting on
my first days at a school for baby
judges y'all may recall that and I
mentioned to you that one of the first
things they told us was that we had to
be good listeners and be patient
in you as judges in this trial have
certainly passed the test thank you for
being good listeners and for being
patient with us it's been quite a long
journey but we're here today to talk
about the other thing they told us in
baby judge school and that was that we
had to give all the parties in front of
us a fair hearing an opportunity to be
heard an opportunity to cross-examine
witnesses an opportunity to bring
evidence and that's what I want to talk
to you about today because in terms of
fundamental fairness subpoenas by the
Senate in this trial would mitigate the
damage caused by the president's
wholesale obstruction of the house
inquiry the president claims that there
is no direct evidence of his wrongdoing
despite direct evidence to the contrary
an ambassador of Bolton's offer to
testify to even more evidence in a trial
but let's not forget that the president
is arguing that there is no direct
evidence while blocking all of us from
getting that direct evidence it's a
remarkable position that they have taken
quite frankly never as a lawyer or a
former judge have I ever seen anything
like this and for the first time in our
history
president Trump ordered his entire
administration his entire administration
to defy every single impeachment
subpoena the Trump administration has
not
a single document in response to the
congressional subpoenas not a single
page nada
that's never happened before there is no
legal privilege to justify the blanket
blocking of all these documents we know
that there are more relevant documents
there is no dispute about that
it is uncontested witnesses have
testified in exceptional detail about
these documents that exist that the
president is simply hiding president's
trump blanket order prohibiting the
entire executive branch from
participating in impeachment
investigation also extended to witnesses
12 8 all followed that order and refused
to testify much of the critical evidence
we have is a result of career officials
bravely coming forward despite the
president's obstruction but those
closest to the president some may say
like in the musical Hamilton those in
the room when it happened
followed his instruction the president
does not dispute that this witnesses
have information that it's relevant to
this trial that these individuals have
personal and direct knowledge of the
president's actions and motivations and
can provide the very evidence he says
now that we don't have now the
president's counsel alleged the house
managers hid evidence from you because
as house managers really their goal
should be to give you all of the facts
because they're asking you to do
something very very consequential and
ask yourself ask yourself
given the facts you've heard today that
they didn't tell you who doesn't want to
talk about the facts who doesn't want to
talk about the facts impeachment
shouldn't be a shell game they should
give you the facts this is nice rhetoric
but it's simply incorrect the
President's Council cherry-picked
misleading bits of evidence cited
disposition transcripts of witnesses who
subsequently corrected their testimony
and public hearings and said the
opposite and in some cases simply left
out the second half of witness
statements that's how the house managers
actually presented the relevant evidence
to you we spent about 20 hours
presenting the facts in the evidence the
president's counsel spent four hours
focusing on the facts and the evidence
and that evidence shows that the
president is guilty but to the extent
certain facts were shown to you let's be
very clear we are not the ones hiding
the facts the house managers did not
hide that evidence president Trump hid
the evidence and that's why we are the
ones standing up here asking you to not
let the president silent this witnesses
and hide these documents we don't know
precisely what the witnesses will say or
what the documents will show that we all
deserve to hear the truth
and more importantly the American people
deserve to hear the truth never before
has a president been put himself above
the law
it hid the facts of his offenses from
the American people like this one we
cannot let this president be different
quite simply the stakes are too high
SEC
as this builds on what we have been
arguing the Senate requires it should
want a complete evidentiary record
before you vote on the most sacred test
that the Constitution entrusts in every
single one of you I can respect that
some of you have deep beliefs that the
removal of this president would be
divisive others you may believe that
allowing this president to remain in the
Oval Office would be catastrophic to our
republic and our democracy but
regardless of where you are regardless
of where you land on this spectrum you
should want a full and complete record
before you make a final decision and to
understand the full story it should not
be about party affiliation it should be
about seeing all the evidence and voting
your conscience based on all the
relevant facts it should be about doing
impartial justice consider the harm done
to our institutions our constitutional
order and the public faith in our
democracy if the Senate chooses to
closes closed its eyes to learning the
full truth about the president's
misconduct how can the American people
have confidence in the result of a trial
without witnesses third the president
should want a fair trial he has
repeatedly said that publicly that he
wants a trial and the merits he
specifically said it you saw a clip that
he wanted a fair trial in the Senate and
that would like what it would have to be
with witnesses that testify including
john bolton
and Mick Mulvaney he said that he wants
a complete and total exoneration well
whatever you say about this trial there
could not be a total an exoneration
without hearing from those
witnesses because an acquittal on an
incomplete record after a trial like in
witnesses in evidence will be no
exoneration it will be no vindication
not for the president not for this
chamber and not for the American people
and if the president is telling the
truth and he did nothing wrong and the
evidence would prove that then we all
know that he would be an enthusiastic
supporter of subpoenas he would be here
probably himself if he could urging you
to do subpoenas if he had information
that would prove he was totally and that
in not in the wrong if he is innocent he
should have nothing to hide his counsel
should be the ones here asking today
disappea de Bolton and Mulvaney and
others for testimony the president would
be eager to have the people closest to
him to testify about his innocence he
would be eager to present the documents
that show he was concerned about
corruption in burden-sharing but the
fact that he has so strenuously opposed
the testimony of his closest advisors
and all the documents speaks volumes
you should issue subpoenas to the
president so that the president can get
the fair trial that he wanted but more
importantly so the American people can
get the fair trial that they deserve the
American people deserve a fair trial I
said at the onset of this trial that one
of the most important decisions you
would make at this moment in history
will not be whether you convict or
acquit but whether the President and the
American people will get a fair trial
the process is more than just the
ultimate decision because the faith in
our institution depends on the
perception of a fair process a vote
against witnesses and documents under
undermines that faith senators
the American people want a fair trial
the overwhelming majority of Americans 3
in for voters 3 in for as a this past
Tuesday believe that this trial should
have witnesses now there's not much that
the American people agree on these days
but they do agree on that and they know
what a fair trial is that involves
witnesses and it involves evidence the
American people deserve to know the
facts about their president's conduct
and those around him and they deserve to
have confidence in this process
confidence that you made the right
decision in order to have that
confidence the Senate must call relevant
witnesses and obtain revelant documents
with health thus far by this president
the American people deserve a fair trial
and now yield to my colleague manager
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
counsel for the president last week the
house managers argued for the testimony
of four witnesses Ambassador John Bolton
Mick Mulvaney Robert Blair and Michael
Duffy and during the presentations from
both parties that has become abundantly
clear why the direct testimony from
those witnesses is so critical and new
evidence continues to underscore that
importance so let's start with John
Bolton the president's counsel has
repeatedly stated that the president
didn't personally tell any of our
witnesses that he linked the military
aid to the investigations there was
simply no evidence anywhere the
president Trump ever linked security
assistance to any investigations most of
the Democrats witnesses have never
spoken to the president at all let alone
about Ukraine security assistance not a
single witness testified that the
President himself said that there was
any connection between any
investigations and security assistance a
presidential meeting or anything else
simply not true as the testimony of
ambassador Tomlin and the admission of
Mick Mulvaney make very clear the
evidence before you proves that the
president only linked the aid to the
investigations he also conditioned both
the White House meeting and the aide on
Ukraine's announcement of the
investigations but if you want more a
witness to acknowledge that the
president told them directly that the
aid was linked a witness in front of you
then you have the power to ask for it
I mentioned this portion there's a slide
I mentioned this portion of ambassador's
manuscript in the beginning and manager
Schiff referenced it as well but he says
directly that the president told him
this now the president has publicly
lashed out in recent days and ambassador
Bolden he says that ambassador boldness
what ambassador Bolton is saying is
nasty and untrue but denials and 280
characters is not the
as testimony under oath we know that
let's put ambassador Bolden under oath
and ask him point-blank did the
president use 391 million dollars of
taxpayer money military aid intended for
an ally at war to pressure Ukraine to
investigate his 2020 opponent the stakes
are too high not to I'd like to briefly
walk you through why ambassador Bolton's
testimony is essential to ensuring a
fair trial also addressing some of the
questions you've asked in the past two
days first turning back to ambassador
Bolton's manuscript the president's
counsel has said no scheme existed and
the president's counsel has cited
repeated denials public denials of
president Trump's inner circle about
boldness allegations
none of them of course under oath and as
we know from the testimony of ambassador
Bolden how important being sworn in
really is but ambassador Bolton is the
top national security aide has direct
insight into the president's inner
circle and he is willing to testify
under oath whether a quote everyone was
in the loop as he testified before
ambassador Bolton reportedly knows quote
new details about senior cabinet
officials who have publicly tried to
sidestep involvement in quote including
secretary Pompeo
and mr. Mulvaney's knowledge of this
scheme second ambassador Bolton has
direct knowledge of key events outside
of the July 25th call that confirmed the
president's scheme remember this is
exactly the type of direct evidence the
president's counsel say doesn't exist
that's partly because they would like
you to believe that the July 25th call
makes up all of the evidence of our case
the call of course is just a part of the
large body of evidence that you've heard
about the past week but it is a key part
but ambassador Bolton has critical
insight into the president's misconduct
outside of this call and you should hear
it take for example the July 10th
meeting with US and Ukrainian officials
at the White House
dr. hill testified during the meeting
that ambassador Sandlin said that he had
a deal with mr. Mulvaney to schedule a
White House meeting if the Ukrainians
did the investigations
according to dr. hill when ambassador
Bolton learned this he told her to go
back to the NSA's legal adviser John
Eisenberg and tell him quote I am NOT a
part of whatever drug deal Sandlin and
Mulvaney are cooking up on this and
quote we already have corroboration of
dr. hills testimony from other witnesses
like lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh and we
have new corroboration from Ukraine to
oleksander Denny look president
zelinsky's former national security
adviser recently confirmed in an
interview that the quote roadmap for
u.s. ukraine relations should have been
the substance but the investigations
were raised in quote Denny look also
explained why this was so problematic he
raised concerns that being quote dragged
into this internal process would be
really bad for the country and also if
there's something that violates US law
that's up to the u.s. to handle in quote
didn't he look elaborated that there
were serious things to discuss at the
meeting but if instead Ukraine was being
dragged into quote internal politics
using our president who is fresh on the
job an experience that could just
destroy everything in quote another key
defense raised by the president has been
that Ukraine felt no pressure that these
investigations are entirely proper well
here's Ukraine saying the opposite of
that you know what else Denny looked
said in the interview quote it was
definitely John who I trusted in quote
talking about Ambassador Bolden so if
you want to know whether Ukrainians felt
pressured call John Bolton as a witness
he was trusted by Ukraine and he was
there for these key meetings and he was
so concerned that he characterized the
scheme as a drug deal and urged dr. Hill
and others to report their concerns to
NSC Legal Counsel who reports the White
House Counsel Cipollone II so let's ask
ambassador Bolden these questions
directly under oath
the president says Ukraine felt no
pressure that soliciting these
investigations wasn't improper is that
true if it is true why is Ukraine
publicly saying that the talk of
investigations could destroy everything
and if the president's administration
thought this was okay why did you use
the words drug deal we should ask him
that why did you urge your staff to
report concerns to lawyers these are all
questions that we can get the answers to
third the president has suggested the
house managers have not presented any
direct evidence about mr. Giuliani's
role in the scheme in fact it appears
the House Committee wasn't particularly
interested in presenting you with any
direct evidence of what major mayor
Giuliani did or why he did it
instead they ask you to rely on hearsay
speculation and assumption evidence that
would be inadmissible in any court
well once again that's simply not true
but if you want more evidence we know
that ambassador Bolden has direct
evidence of mr. Giuliani's role
regarding Ukraine and expressed concerns
about it the president has suggested
that mr. Giuliani wasn't doing anything
improper and he was not involved in
conducting policy by their own admission
they said he wasn't doing policy so
let's ask John Bolton what Giuliani was
doing and whether the investigations
were politically motivated or part of
our foreign policy he would know dr.
hill testified that ambassador Bolden
said Mr Giuliani was quote a
hand-grenade which he explained referred
to quote all of the statements that mr.
Giuliani was making publicly that the
investigation is that he was promoting
that the story line he was promoting the
narrative he was promoting was going to
backfire in quote the narrative mr.
Giuliani was promoting of course was
asking Ukraine to dig up dirt on Biden
dr. hill also testified that ambassador
Bolton was so concerned he told dr. hill
and other members of
in a sea staff quote nobody should be
meeting with Giuliani in quote and that
was quote closely monitoring what mr.
Giuliani was doing in the messaging that
he was sending out in quote so let's ask
ambassador Bolton if mr. Giuliani wasn't
doing anything wrong why were you so
concerned about his behavior that you
directed your staff to have no part in
this if mr. Giuliani wasn't trying to
dig up dirt on Biden why did you seem to
think he was that he could quote blow
everything up forth the president has
said that there was nothing wrong with
the July 25th call but once again the
evidence suggests that ambassador Bolton
would testify that the opposite is true
according to witness testimony
ambassador Bolden expressed concerns
even before the call that it would be
quote a disaster because he thought
there would be quote talk of
investigations or worse now if the
president would have you believe that
the call was perfect as he's repeatedly
stated why don't we find out because all
of the evidence before you suggests
otherwise and Ukraine knows this is not
the case the call was not perfect
any look is clear on this point he said
quote one thing I can tell you that was
clear from this July 25th call is that
the issue of the investigations is an
issue of concern for Trump and quote or
it was clear but if there's still any
uncertainty we must ask ambassador
Bolden if there was no scheme how did
you know President Trump would raise
investigations on the call what made you
so concerned a call would be a disaster
v the president's main defense once
again is that he withheld the military
aid for a legitimate reason but the
evidence doesn't support that we've
heard a lot the evidence doesn't support
that witness testimony emails and other
documents confirm that ambassador Bolton
and his subordinates on many occasions
including through in-person meetings
with the President himself
urged the president that there was no
legitimate reason to withhold the aid
but if you're not sure if you think this
could in any way have been about a
legitimate policy reason let's ask the
National Security Advisor who was in
charge of that if this was simply a
policy dispute as the president argues
let's ask John Bolton whether that's
true
the president also argues that you
cannot evaluate the president's
subjective intent that the president can
use his power any way he feels is
appropriate that's of course not the
case whether his intent was a corrupt is
a central part of this case as it is in
nearly every criminal case in the
country as a backup Garg
argument however the president claims
that that you know we want you to read
the president's mind juries of course is
seen entire impeachment process is about
the house managers insistence that they
are able to read everybody's thoughts
they can read everybody's intention they
think you can read minds they want to
tell you what President Trump thought
our Tsar routinely asked to determine
the defendants state of mind that's
central to almost every criminal case in
the country and it's disingenuous for
the president's counsel to argue that
the defendants state of mind is
unknowable that it requires a
mind-reader or is anything but the most
common element of proof of any crime
constitutional or otherwise but if you
want more information let's ask the
president whether John Bolton can help
fill in any gaps about his state of mind
if you think about it John he knows some
of my thoughts he knows what I think
about leaders case is about the
president's conduct in Ukraine John
Bolton knows a lot about that let's hear
from him a fair trial demands it and
it's more than just ensuring a fair
trial it's about remembering that an
America
truth matters as mr. Bolton's sit on
January 30th quote the idea that somehow
testifying to what do you think is true
is destructive to the system of
government we have I think is very
nearly the reverse the exact reverse of
the truth in quote now as manager shift
started this out the truth continues to
come out again in an article today more
information the truth will come out and
it's continuing to the question here
before this body is what do you want
your place in history to be do you want
your place in history to be let's hear
the truth or that we don't want to hear
it given our time constraints we will
now summarize the reasons why mr.
Mulvaney mr. Duffy and mr. Blair are
also important let's turn first to mr.
Mulvaney to begin with mr. Mulvaney
participated in meetings and discussions
with President Trump at every single
stage of this scheme we just talked
about motive and intent well if you want
further insight into the president's
motives or intent further direct
evidence of why he withheld the military
aid and the White House meeting you
should call his acting chief of staff
who had more access than anyone mr.
Mulvaney is important because the
President's Council continues to argue
incorrectly that our evidence is just
hearsay and speculation
face wood ambassador Sunland and mr.
home saying this was all as clear as two
plus two equals four the president says
they are just guessing that is simply
not true
the evidence is direct the evidence is
compelling and confirmed by many
witnesses corroborated by text messages
emails and phone records but if you want
more evidence if you want another
first-hand account for why the aid was
withheld for the undisputed quid pro quo
for that White House meeting let's just
hear from Mick Mulvaney over and over
again
ambassador Soglin described to multiple
witnesses how mr. Mulvaney was directly
involved in the president's scheme
here's some of that testimony and so
when I came in Gaudin sumblind was
basically saying well look we have a
deal here that there will be a meeting I
have a deal here with with chief of
staff Mulvaney there will be a meeting
if the Ukrainians
open up or announced these
investigations and into 2016 in BER yzma
and I cut it off immediately there
combusted a Bolton told me that I am not
part of this whatever drug deal that
Mulvaney and Sunderland are cooking up
what did you understand him to mean by
the drug deal that Mulvaney and Sandlin
were cooking up I took it to mean
investigations for a meeting did you go
speak to the lawyers I certainly did
what I want to ask you about is he makes
reference in that drug deal to a drug
deal cooked up by you and Mulvaney
it's the reference to Mulvaney that I
want to ask you about you've testified
and that Mulvaney was aware of this quid
pro quo of this condition that the
Ukrainians had to meet that is
announcing these public investigations
to get the White House meetings that
right
yeah a lot of people were aware of it
and including about including mr.
Mulvaney correct remarkably the
president is still denying the facts
even as they argue that if it's true
it's still not impeachable but if the
president did nothing wrong if he held
up the aid because of so-called
corruption or burden-sharing reasons he
should want his chief of staff to come
testify under oath before this
distinguished body and say just that why
doesn't he want
Mulvaney to appear before the United
States Senate well we know the answer
because mr. Mulvaney will confirm the
corrupt shakedown scheme because mr.
Mulvaney was in the loop everyone was in
the loop as ambassador Stalin summarized
in his testimony on July 19 he emailed
several top administration officials
including mr. Mulvaney that president
szalinski was prepared to receive POTUS
his call and would assure President
Trump that he intends to run a fully
transparent investigation and will turn
over every stone mr. Mulvaney replied I
asked NSC to set it up for tomorrow the
above email seems clear
ambassador Solomon testified that it was
clear that he was confirming to mr.
Mulvaney that he had told president
szalinski he had to tell President Trump
on that July 25th call that he would
announce the investigation which he
explained was a reference to one of the
two
phony political investigations that
President Trump wanted and mr. Mulvaney
replies that he'll set up the meeting
consistent with the agreement that
sunland explained he'd reach with mr.
Mulvaney to condition a meeting on the
investigations but if there's any
uncertainty if there's any lingering
questions about what this means let's
just question Mick Mulvaney under oath
sylvania also matters because we have
heard several questions from this
distinguished body of senators wanting
to understand when or why or how the
president ordered the hold on the
security aid as the head of the Office
of Management and Budget mr. Mulvaney
has unique insights into all of these
questions your questions remember that
email exchange between mr. Mulvaney and
his deputy Rob Blair on June 27th when
Mulvaney asked Blair about whether they
could implement the whole and Blair
responded that it could be done but that
Congress would become unhinged it wasn't
just Congress it was the Independent
Government Accountability Office that
determined that the president's hold
violated the law what if the President's
Council is going to argue without
evidence that he withheld the aid as
part of u.s. foreign policy seems to
make sense that the Senate should hear
directly from mr. Mulvaney who has
first-hand knowledge of exactly these
facts he said so
himself again I was I was involved with
the the process by which the money was
held up temporarily
why doesn't President Trump want Mick
Mulvaney to testify why
perhaps here's why that he also
mentioned to me and past the the the the
the corruption related to the DNC server
absolutely no question about that but
that's it that's why we held up the
money now there was a report so the
demand for an investigation into the
Democrats was part of the reason that he
it was on to withhold funding to Ukraine
we look back to what happened in 2016 I
certainly was was part of the thing that
he was worried about in corruption with
that nation and that is absolutely you
just described is a quid pro quo it is
funding will not flow unless the
investigation into the democratic server
happened as well we do we do that all
the time with foreign policy we were
holding up money at the same time for
what was it the northern triangle come
countries we're holding a beta at the
northern triangle countries so that they
so that they would change their policies
on immigration but by the way and this
speaks to a distort what I'm sorry this
speaks to important point because I
heard this yesterday that I could never
remember the gentleman who test was
McKinney the guy is that his name from
the I don't know I he testified
yesterday and if you go and if you
believe the news reports okay because
we've not seen any transcripts of this
the only transcript I've seen was
someone's testimony morning this morning
if you read the news reports and you
believe them what a McKinney say
yesterday well McKinney said yesterday
that he was really upset with the
political influence in foreign policy
that was one of the reasons he was so
upset about this and I have news for
everybody get over it
there's going to be political influence
in foreign policy fine is that what the
Constitution requires get over it is
that good enough for this body the
world's greatest deliberative body get
over it
the President's Council can try to
emphasize mr. Mulvaney and his attorneys
efforts to walk
back this statement but as you've seen
with your own eyes the statement was
unequivocal and even when given the
chance in real time on that day on
October 17th to deny a quid pro quo he
doubled down get over it
he said but if you have any questions
about what the real answer is where the
truth lies there's only one way to find
out let's all just question mr. Mulvaney
under oath during a Senate trial after
all counsel said that cross-examination
was the greatest vehicle in the history
of American jurisprudence ever invented
to ascertain the truth your standard
finally I'd like to touch briefly on the
importance of Mr Blair and mr. Duffy to
this case the president's lawyers have
argued that withholding foreign aid is
entirely within his right as
commander-in-chief that this was a
normal ordinary decision and that this
is all just one big policy disagreement
we have proven exactly the opposite this
can't be a policy disagreement because
the president's hold actually went
against US policy the hold was
undertaken outside of the normal
channels by a president who they admit
was not conducting policy the hold was
concealed not only from Congress but
from the president's own officials
responsible for Ukraine policy and most
importantly the hold violated the law
the president has the right to make
policy but he does not have the right to
break the law
and coercion li and to helping him cheat
in our free and fair elections and he
doesn't have a right to use hundreds of
millions of dollars in taxpayer funds as
leverage to get political dirt on an
American citizen who happens to be his
political opponent but if you remain
unsure about all of this who better to
ask than Mr Blair or mr. Duffy they
oversaw and executed the process of
withholding the aid they can tell us
exactly how unrelated to business as
usual
this whole shakedown scheme was when it
was under way they can testify about why
the aid was withheld and whether there
was any legitimate explanation for
withholding it some of you have asked
that very question multiple officials
including ambassador Sandlin ambassador
Taylor David Holmes lieutenant colonel
VIN Minh Jennifer Williams and mark
sandy all testified that they were never
given a credible explanation for the
whole so let's ask mr. Blair let's ask
mr. Duffy if this happens all the time
as Mick Mulvaney suggests why at this
time in connection with this scheme for
all of those witnesses left in the dark
despite the president's refusal to
produce a single document to produce a
shred of information in this impeachment
inquiry undertaken in the house his
administration did produce 192 pages
of Ukraine related email records and
Freedom of Information Act lawsuits I'll
be it in heavily redacted form these
documents confirm mr. Duffy's central
role in executing the hold
he's on nearly every single email
released nearly every single email
here's an important email from that
production just 90 minutes after the
July 25th call mr. Duffy emailed
officials at the Department of Defense
that they should hold off on any
additional DoD obligations of these
funds mr. Duffy added that the request
was sensitive and that they should keep
this information closely held the timing
is important because if the aid wasn't
linked to the July 25th call if it
wasn't related why the sensitive closely
held requests made within two hours of
that call let's just ask mr. Duffy mr.
Duffy and mr. Blair can testify about
the concerns raised by DoD to the Office
of Management and Budget about the
illegality of the hold and why it
remained in place even after DoD warned
the administration that it would violate
the impoundment Control Act now the
president of course has disputed this
fact but we have demonstrated that OMB
was warned repeatedly by DoD officials
of two things
first continuing to withhold the aid
would prevent the Department of Defense
from spending the money before the end
of the fiscal year and second the hold
was potentially illegal as turned out to
be the case by August ninth dld told mr.
Duffy directly that dld the Department
of Defense could no longer support the
Office of Management and budgets claims
that the hold would not preclude timely
execution of the aid for Ukraine our
vulnerable ally at war with Russian
backed separatists yet as mr. Duffy
reportedly told misma Custer at the
Department of Defense on August 30th
there was a clear direction from POTUS
to continue the whole clear direction
from the President of the United States
to continue the hold so how did mr.
Duffy understand the clear direction to
continue the hole why is the president
claiming that this wasn't unlawful when
dld the Department of Defense repeatedly
warned his administration that it was
wouldn't we all like to ask mr. Duffy
these questions
finally here's another reason why we
know this was not business as usual on
July 29th mr. Duffy a political
appointee with zero relevant experience
abruptly sees responsibility for
withholding the aide from mark sandy a
career Office of Management and Budget
official seized the responsibility from
a career of
mr. Duffy provided no credible
explanation for that decision mr. sandy
testified that nothing like that had
ever happened in his entire governmental
career let's think about that if this is
as routine as the president claims why
is a career official saying he's never
seen anything like this happened before
mr. Duffy knows why shouldn't we just
take the time to ask him the American
people deserve a fair trial the
Constitution deserves a fair trial the
president deserves a fair trial a fair
trial means witnesses a fair trial means
documents a fair trial means evidence no
one is above the law and now yield to my
distinguished colleague manager Lofgren
mr. Chief Justice and Senators it's not
just about hearing from witnesses you
need documents the documents don't lie
there are specific documents relevant to
this to this impeachment trial in the
custody of the White House OMB DoD and
the State Department and the president
has hidden them from us I'm not going to
go through each category again in detail
but here are some observations this is
of course an impeachment case against
the President of the United States
nothing could be more important and the
most important documents documents that
go directly to who knew what when are
being held by the executive branch many
of these records are at the White House
the White House has records about the
phone calls with President Zielinski
about scheduling an oval office meeting
with President Solinsky about the
president's decision to hold security
assistance about communications among
his top aides about concerns raised by
public officials with legal counsel
we've heard about ambassador Bolton's
handwritten notes and book manuscript
and lieutenant-colonel VIN Mann's
presidential policy memorandum we know
of reports about a number of emails in
early August trying to create after the
fact justifications for the hold but we
haven't seen any of them there at the
White House being hidden by the
president I think it's a cover-up
documents at the State Department
records about the recall of ambassador
yovanovich about mr. Giuliani's efforts
for the president about concerns raised
about the hold about the Ukranian
reaction to the hold and when exactly
they learned about it about negotiations
with the Ukrainians for an oval office
meeting we know of ambassador Taylor's
first-person cable and notes and mr.
Kent's memos to file we know about mr.
salads email
with Pompeo and Brett ball and Mulvaney
and Perry but we haven't seen them
they're sitting at the State Department
DoD and OMB also have records records
about president Trump's hold on military
aid Ukraine about the justification for
the hold about hiding the hold from
Congress and trying to justify the hold
after the fact and about why the hold
was lifted but we haven't seen them
there at DoD and OMB why haven't we seen
them because the president directed all
of his agencies not to produce them this
trial should not reward the president's
really unprecedented obstruction by
allowing him to control what evidence
you see and what will remain hidden you
should ask for these documents on behalf
of the American people and you should
ask for these documents to get the truth
yourself now let's come back to the
issue of delay since the president's
lawyers have suggested that having
witnesses and documents would make this
trial take too long there will be
lengthy court battles they say the
president might even invoke executive
privilege for the very very first time
in this entire impeachment process it
would be better we're told to skip
straight to the final verdict to break
from centuries of precedent and end this
trial without hearing from a single
witness without reviewing a single
document that the president ordered
hidden respectfully that shouldn't
happen house managers aren't interested
in delaying these proceedings were
interested in the full truth in a trial
that is fair to the parties and to the
American people in the facts of the
President's Council agrees are so
critical to this trial it's why we said
we won't go to court we'll follow all
the rulings of the Chief Justice we can
get the witness depositions done in a
week in fact I know we can because if
you the Senators order it that's the law
you have the sole
our to try impeachments if questions or
objections come up including objections
based on executive privilege the senate
itself and the chief justice in the
first instance can resolve them
we aren't suggesting that the president
waive executive privilege
we simply suggest that the Chief Justice
can resolve issues related to any
assertion of executive privilege as the
Supreme Court recognized in the case of
Judge Walter Nixon judges will stay out
of disputes over how the Senate
exercises its sole power to try
impeachments that ensures there will be
no unnecessary delay and it's why we
propose we suspend the trial for one
week and that during that time you go
back to business as usual while the
trial is suspended will take witness
depositions review the documents that
are provided at your direction the four
witnesses who should hear from are
readily available
ambassador Bolton has already said he
will appear we can and would move
quickly to depose these witnesses within
a week of the issuance of subpoenas the
documents too are ready to be produced
we're ready to review them quickly and
to present additional evidence meanwhile
the Senate can continue going about its
important legislative work as it did
during the depositions in the Clinton
impeachment trial the president's
opposition to this suggestion says a lot
the president is the architect of the
very delay he warns against he could
easily avoid it he could move things
along he could stop trying to silence
witnesses and hide evidence I think he's
afraid the truth will come out
he hopes his threats of continued delay
however unjustified will cause you to
throw up your hands and give up on a
fair trial please don't give up this is
too important for our democracy a
decision to forego witnesses and
documents at this trial would be a big
departure from Senate
when the Senate investigated Watergate
it heard from the highest White House
officials that happened because a
bipartisan majority of the Senate
insisted we got to the truth then
because the Senate came together and put
a fair proceeding above party loyalty we
should all want the truth and so we
asked you do it again that you put aside
any politics party loyalty belief in
your president which we understand and
sympathize with but subpoena the
documents and the witnesses necessary to
make this a fair trial to hear and see
the evidence you need to impart the
administer justice now there's been a
lot of discussion of executive privilege
during this trial even if the president
asserts executive privilege something he
has not yet done it wouldn't harm the
president's legal rights or cause undue
delay and here's why let's focus on John
Bolten since this week's revelations
confirm the importance of his testimony
first as a private citizen John Bolton
is fully protected by the First
Amendment if he wants to testify there's
no basis for imposing prior restraint
for censoring him just because some of
his testimony could include
conversations with the president that's
commonplace as long as his testimony
isn't classified it is shielded by the
free speech Clause by the First
Amendment
ambassador Bolton has written a book
it's inconceivable that he is forbidden
from telling the United States Senate
sitting is a high court of impeachment
information that shortly will be in
print if the President did attempt to
invoke executive privilege he would fail
it's true for two separate reasons first
claims of executive privilege always
involved a balancing of interests the
Supreme Court confirmed in US v Nixon
the Nixon tapes case that executive
privilege can be overcome by a need for
evidence in a criminal trial that is
even more true here in an impeachment
trial of the President of the United
States which is probably the most
important interest under the
Constitution
it would certainly outweigh any claim of
privilege precedent confirms the point
to name just a few national security
advisors for President Carter Sevigny
Brzezinski President Clinton Samuel
burger president george w bush
Condoleezza Rice and President Obama
Susan Rice testified in congressional
investigations these advisers discussed
their communications with top government
officials including the presidents they
served there's no reason why all these
officials could not testify in the
normal course of events and hearings but
ambassador Bolton a former official
couldn't testify in the most important
trial there could possibly be the second
reason is the president waived any claim
of executive privilege about ambassador
Bolton's testimony all seventeen
witnesses testified in the house about
these matters without any assertion of
privilege by the President President
Trump as well as his lawyers and senior
officials have publicly discussed and
tweeted about these issues at some
length the president has also directly
denied reports about what ambassador
Bolton will say in his forthcoming book
under these circumstances the president
can't be held cannot be allowed to tell
his version of the story to the public
while using executive privilege to
silence a key witness who would
contradict him you shouldn't let the
president escape responsibility only to
later see clearly what happened in
ambassador Bolton's book there are no
national security risks here the
president has Declassified the two phone
calls with president szalinski all
seventeen witnesses testified about the
president's conduct regarding Ukraine we
aren't interested in
excu about anything other than Ukraine
that's simply a bogus argument the
Constitution uses the word sole power
only twice first when it gives the house
sole power to impeach and second article
1 section 3 where it gives the Senate
sole power to try and pre impeachments
and here's what it says the Senate shall
have the sole power to try all
impeachments when the president of the
United States is tried the Chief Justice
shall preside now I think that provision
in the Constitution means something it's
up to the Senate to decide how to try
this impeachment with fairness with
witnesses and documents privileges
asserted can be decided using the
process that you devised that's not
unconstitutional
it's what the Constitution provides you
have the power you decide please decide
for a fair trial that will yield the
truth and serve our Constitution and the
American people I yield now to
managership senators before we yield to
counsel with the president I'd like to
take a moment by talking about what I
think is at stake here
a no vote on the question before you
will have long-lasting and harmful
consequences long after this impeachment
trial is over we agree with the
president's counsel on this much this
will set a new precedent this will be
cited in impeachment trials from this
point to the end of history
you can bet in every impeachment that
follows whether it is a presidential
impeachment or the impeachment of a
judge if that judge or President
believes that it is to his or her
advantage that there shall be a trial
with no witnesses they will cite the
case of Donald J Trump
they will make the argument that you can
adjudicate the guilt or innocence of the
party who is accused without hearing
from a single witness without reviewing
a single document and I would submit
that will be a very dangerous and
long-lasting precedent that we will all
have to live with president Trump's
wholesale obstruction of Congress
strikes at the heart of our Constitution
and democratic system of separation of
powers make no mistake the president's
actions in this impeachment inquiry
constitute an attack on congressional
oversight on the co-equal nature of this
branch of government not just on a house
but on the Senate's ability as well to
conduct its oversight to serve as a
check and balance on this president and
every president that follows if the
Senate allows president Trump's
obstruction to stand it effectively
nullifies the impeachment power it will
allow future presidents to decide
whether they want their misconduct to be
investigated or not whether they would
like to participate in an impeachment
investigation or not that is a power of
the Congress that is not a power of the
President by permitting a categorical
obstruction it turns the impeachment
power against itself how do we respond
to this unprecedented obstruction will
shape future debates between our
branches of government and the executive
forever and it's not just at Pietschmann
the ability of Congress to conduct
meaningful and probing oversight
oversight that by its nature is intended
to be a check and balance on the awesome
powers of the executive branch hinges on
our willingness to call witnesses and
compel documents that President Trump is
hiding with no valid justification no
presidential support if we tell the
president effectively you can act
corruptly you can abuse the powers of
your office to coerce a foreign
government to helping you cheat in an
election by withholding military aid
when you're caught you can further abuse
your powers by concealing the evidence
of your wrongdoing the president becomes
unaccountable to anyone our government
is no longer a government with three
co-equal branches the president
effectively for all intents and purposes
becomes above the law this is of course
the opposite of what the framers
intended they purposely entrusted the
power of impeachment to the legislative
branch so that it may protect the
American people from a president who
believes that he can do whatever he
wants so we must consider how our
actions will reverberate for decades to
come and the impact they will have on
the functioning of our democracy and as
we consider this critical decision it's
important to remember that no matter
what you decide to do here whether you
decide to hear witnesses and relevant
testimony the facts will come out in the
end even over the course of this trial
we have seen so many additional facts
come to light the facts will come out in
all of their horror they will come out
and there are more court documents and
deadlines under the Freedom of
Information Act witnesses will tell
their stories and future congressional
hearings in books and in the media this
week has made that abundantly clear the
documents the president is hiding will
come out the witnesses the president is
concealing will tell their stories and
we will be asked why we didn't want to
hear that information when we had the
chance when we could consider its
relevance and importance in making this
most serious decision what answer shall
we give if we do not pursue the
now if we allow it to remain hidden
until it is too late to consider on the
profound issue of the president's
innocent or guilt what we are asking you
to do on behalf of the American people
is simple use your sole power to try
impeachment by holding a fair trial get
the documents they refuse to provide to
the house here are the witnesses they
refuse to make available to the house
just as this body has done in every
single impeachment trial until now let
the American people know that you
understand they deserve the truth
let them know you still care about the
truth that the truth still matters
though much divides us on this we should
agree a trial stripped of all its
trappings should be a search for the
truth and that requires witnesses and
testimony now you may have seen just
this afternoon the former president's
former chief of staff general Kelly said
a Senate trial without witnesses is a
job only half-done trial without
witnesses is only half a trial well I
have to say I can't agree a trial
without witnesses no trial at all you
either have a trial or you don't and if
you're going to have a real trial you
need to hear from the people who have
first-hand information now we presented
some of them to you but you know as well
as we there are others that you should
hear from but let me close this portion
with words I think more powerful than
Jen
Kellie's and they come from John Adams
who in 1776 wrote together with the
right to vote those who wrote our
constitution considered the right to
trial by jury the heart and lungs the
mainspring and the center wheel of our
liberties without which the body must
die the watch must run down the
government must become arbitrary now
what does that mean without a fair trial
the government must become arbitrary now
of course he's talking about the right
of an average citizen to a trial by jury
well if in courtrooms all across America
when someone is tried but they're a
person of influence and power they could
declare at the beginning of the trial if
the government's case is so good let him
prove it without witnesses if people of
power and influence can insist to the
judge that the house that the
prosecutors that the government that the
people must prove their case without
witnesses or documents a right reserved
only for the powerful because you know
only Donald Trump only Donald Trump of
any defendant in America can insist on a
trial with no witnesses if that should
be true and courts throughout the land
then as Adams wrote the government
becomes arbitrary because whether you
have a fair trial or no trial it all
depends on whether you are a person of
power and influence like Donald J Trump
the body will die the clock will run
down and our government becomes
arbitrary the importance of fair trial
here is not less than in every courtroom
in America it is greater than any
courtroom in America because we set the
example for America I said at the outset
and I'll repeat again your decision on
guilt or innocence is important but it's
not the most important decision if we
have a fair trial however that trial
turns out whatever your verdict may be
at least we can agree we had a fair
trial at least we can agree that the
house had a fair opportunity presents
its case at least we can agree that the
president a fair opportunity to present
their case if we have a fair trial and
we can disagree about the verdict but we
can all agree the system worked as it
was intended we had a fair trial and we
reached a decision
Rob this country of a fair trial and
there can be no representation that the
verdict has any meaning how could it if
the result is baked in by the process
assure the American people whatever the
result may be that at least they got a
fair shake there's a reason why the
American people want to hear from
witnesses and it's not just about
curiosity it's because they recognize
that in every courtroom in America
that's just what happens and if it
doesn't happen here the government has
become arbitrary there is one person who
is entitled to a different standard and
that's the President of the United
States and that is the last thing the
founders intended we reserve the balance
of our time Thank You mr. manager
majority leader is recognized I request
the Senate take a 15-minute recess
without ordered